one of the things that i say um is the
most courageous thing you can do
above all bravery is
this is the personal life that i really
keep to myself you know i've spoke a lot
about it today which i've never spoken
about before
[Music]
ant middleton and is an adventurer
a military vet a television host an
author an entrepreneur
and one that's become highly highly
respected as an authority when it comes
to things like survival and endurance
and leadership techniques
and due to his experiences as an elite
special
force member he can talk about these
things in a way that nobody
nobody else can and has very very
recently been at the center of a huge
media storm where he was quote unquote
cancelled with his biggest show today
sas judea's wins being axed by channel 4
after
five years and the broadcaster came out
and said that anne's views and values
weren't aligned to theirs this is his
first
in-depth conversation that he's recorded
since he was quote unquote cancelled
i've watched countless amounts of
interviews that ant middleton has done
but the side of ant that you're going to
hear today is one that even he admits
himself
that he has never fully shared before
i'm going to say it
this podcast lifted a ton of weight off
my shoulders and answered maybe the most
important question about life that we
all must ask ourselves
if we are going to be happy and if we're
going to be successful
and if we're going to be free and
thank you for your honesty without
further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
dire of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
and um when i was reading your book
first man in there was um
there's this quote at the end of one of
the chapters and i thought it was a good
place to start this conversation today
because
i tend to think that it's probably one
of the more foundational pieces
of information well it might lead to one
of the most foundational piece of
information to describe who you became
in your life and what you've got on to
achieve
and this is what you you wrote at the
end of the chapter it says it's called
making friends with your demons
having dark forces living within us is
part of being human they're the result
of inevitable damage of life
each one of us has a choice make these
demons work for us
or turn them loose against us and
slightly linked to that
in the same on the same page you wrote
most of most of us have horror stories
we can tell you about from our
childhoods
it's not the horror that defines you
it's how well you fought it
what did that mean i think that's just a
generic message to everyone to say that
it's okay
to have you know bad thoughts it's okay
to have these demons inside you they
exist in all of us
you know but the important message is to
exercise them
because the moment you lock them away
the moment you lock these thoughts away
the moment you lock these demons away
the moment you lock any negativity away
all it's going to do
is take over like a mold and it's going
to completely engulf you
and it's going to going to control you
as an individual
and it's only because i've been there
and i've done it whether that's what
i've done in combat
losing my father at a young age um
losing my mother
um seeing bodies blown up around me
seeing
dead people around me seeing the effect
it has on families
seeing what my decision pulling that
trigger or not
has on a certain person or has on a
certain family or has on a certain
situation
and it's ultimately being okay with who
you are
that's the whole thing about it it's
being acknowledging that listen
we're not perfect we're human okay we
have
weaknesses we have insecurities we have
these horrendous thoughts sometimes
now you'd be a liar to say you don't sit
there sometimes and you know the things
that go through your head if you
actually voice them
then that becomes a problem that's you
not exercising your demons that's
them exercising you and it's just about
acknowledging that
and i acknowledge that from such a young
age
i acknowledged that from a young age
when my father passed away and i
couldn't really understand what was
going on
can you tell me about that um yeah my
father passed away when i was five years
old
and um within a few months
a new man came into our life um my
stepfather
um and then within two years we up
moved to france so we lived in
portsmouth we often moved completely to
france
a new situation a new environment a new
man in our life
and i can just remember thinking i
remember going into
a bush in the fields where we lived in
france
after a couple of months we were there
and i sat in this bush
and the magnitude of the situation was
so overwhelming
i can just remember looking at the road
and thinking to myself
what am i doing here why why am i here
what's the purpose i
i couldn't grasp anything at that young
age
and it was during that moment when i let
everything go
and i can just remember thinking to
myself don't try and understand what's
going on
don't i'm just trying to understand who
this man is and where he's come from
don't try and understand why you're in a
different school speaking a different
language
because you can't don't try and
understand
all of a sudden you're living in
caravans
we moved we were living in a couple of
caravans we were a big
big family um from houses
um and i can just remember dropping
everything and thinking to myself
understand what you can understand and
that at that young age what i could
understand was
what i was feeling you know i could
understand myself
so when i look back on the death of my
father and as i flip everything into a
positive
even though years and years and years
down the line i'd done this
you know the death of my father actually
made me self-reflect
from the age of six or seven
so i've been self-reflecting you know
understanding my emotions understanding
how i feel
understanding my demons understanding
you know the good parts of me the bad
parts to me the
weak parts of me the strong parts of me
the positive side of me the negative
side of me
and i've been really breaking it down
from such a young age and
that's given me an advantage in life
i generally believe that that's given me
my sort of
bulletproof mindset on how to tackle
anyone or any situation today
so even though it's a traumatic
part of my life and it affected me all
the way up to my mid-20s
in in a bad way where i'd go out and try
and understand who my father was trying
to understand
you know i never went to his funeral i
never went to
to to his grave now my parents my
say my parents my stepdad because he
came in my life so young i called him my
dad
um they never told me where he was
buried he was just completely cut out of
our life
um because of the situation beforehand
you know for him to come into our lives
a couple of months after it was pretty
obvious that my mum was obviously having
an affair or there's something going on
and again i'm not judging anyone or the
situation but
you know so when he came into our life
it was like right you call him dad
my name changed from aaron to middleton
not a lot of people know that really
yeah um and this whole new life was just
forced upon me forced upon me so i was
either
forced to act or force not to act
you know sitting in that bush me forcing
not to act was probably jumping in the
road
you know thinking like listen enough is
enough did that cross your mind
it was a big road it was a big road and
it never got to that stage where i
thought right i'm going to take my life
but it was like
you know this there's an easy option out
of here which i mean it's like
there is an easy option out of here but
it never crossed my mind to
to do it but i can just remember
thinking of that road thinking the cars
move fast there
i mean if you wanted to it's more like
if you wanted to
yeah so it crosses your mind yeah it
crosses your mind but it doesn't
register yeah if that makes sense yeah
and it's only you know throughout these
few years when you start to reflect back
on
on who you are and what you've been
through you start to go bloody hell and
actually maybe
i was thinking like that at a young age
so um
but then again you know who i am i you
know i'm honest with myself i'm honest
with my demons i'm honest with
with who i am and ultimately i'm i'm
honest with um
with knowing that we're not perfect you
know a lot of people
and you've described it there they never
make they never
admit their demons to themself and what
ends up happening is those demons
run the show but from the back room
absolutely and you know i guess you see
that a lot
with people that have come back from war
as well because they don't
get the uh the support they need but
i see it during war yeah i see people
level-headed
intelligent soldiers lose their head on
the battlefield come
running past you doing things that you
think
wow where the hell did that come from
you look into their eyes and there's
[ __ ] nothing there nothing there
and then boom they flip out and you're
like
do you realize what you just done like
like you know it's
you know those demons are [ __ ] strong
they're there
how do you address them you have to
exercise them
and you know the way i exercise my
demons is
by getting like-minded similar people in
the same room
in a safe environment and i might drink
myself into oblivion
till three four in the morning you know
chatting about what we've done chatting
about
old times chatting about who we are and
then boom i'm done
for six months you know i've i've
released those demons
when you you know intoxicate yourself
with alcohol it you know
it allows you to talk and i'm not saying
go out there and do that but that's just
my way
of coming from a drinking culture i.e
the military a drinking and a fighting
culture that's the way that we deal with
things
and for now now it might be a blowout
where you know
i go out and you know i'll have a nice
meal and
you know we'll have a few glasses of
wine you know we'll be in a
private room and we we shoot the [ __ ]
and you know just talk about
whatever we need to talk about
whatever's on your mind but also
physically
i exercise my demons physically you know
i put myself in horrendous situations in
order to fight against myself
um everest is a prime example of what's
gonna say um
you know i didn't have to go up during
the storms i you know
if i was the normal sensible person i
would have
went up after that storm went so just
for context you
you decided to climb mount everest with
a buddy of yours
at probably the worst possible time and
you got into a little bit of a
predicament up there
yeah exactly that yeah um to say the
least yeah
but it's one of those where i didn't
just want to walk up
on a nice sunny day you know and
and gain nothing from that experience
what what why though
like why are you voluntarily putting
yourself through
chaos and what anyone else would
perceive to be agony why are you
choosing that
that's me exercising my demons really
that's me
you know pushing myself to that limit
that's me
having tasted that drug of
living on that line of life and death
and a lot of people think that drugs
adrenaline but it's not
i don't feel pumped i don't feel i feel
ultimate peace
so people find this bizarre but when
i walk that line of life and death which
i've done multiple times
it's a pure feeling of euphoria it's not
what you think where you feel pumped in
your your eyes are red and
you've got this aggression going through
you and you have to get through this
moment it's like
life is so uncomplicated steve so
uncomplicated you're either going to
live or you're going to die
all the [ __ ] all the complications
of life
that is implemented on you whether
that's through
government whether that's through work
whether that's true family all of that
goes
and you are left with the most purest
form of life
and it's so uncomplicated that it's so
euphoric
it's so peaceful and when you hear of
world war
one and world war ii poets that are
writing poems in trenches
people are like how the hell are they
writing poems in trenches
i understand that feeling because life
is so uncomplicated it's so pure it's so
peaceful
that they're writing with no stresses no
complications no [ __ ] it's just it's
coming from
the purest form of life of i'm either
going to live or i'm going to die
and it's that feeling that i chase i
chase that feeling well
to want that moment of peace pure and
utter peace
for 10 15 minutes
that drug i chase and that's
crossing those boundaries crossing those
lines crossing any limitations
to the edge of life you take that step
you're gone
you go over that edge you know you're
gonna
feel it you're gonna feel alive you're
gonna feel everything that you need
that you need out of life um but for me
that's exercising my demons
so whether i do it psychologically where
i'm putting myself
in situations that i'm saying stuff that
i believe in that i value that
as a message and it's being contradicted
or whether i'm pushing myself
to a physical limit or putting myself in
a in a physical situation which is
uncomprehendable to to the to the
everyday man or woman
but it's because i've tasted it i've had
the
misfortune i've had
the burden of tasting that drug
and will it be the end of me i can't say
that for sure i can't say that it won't
i can't say that you know i've never put
myself in these situations again because
i find myself constantly doing it
but for me that is exercising my demons
and everyone's demons are different
everyone's situation is different
everyone's emotions are different
everyone's dna is different but that's
me exercising my demons
quick one starting from the minute the
lockdown is lifted we're gonna start
bringing in some of our subscribers to
watch how this podcast is produced
behind the scenes
means you get to meet the guests meet
myself and see how we put all of this
together
if you want that to be you all you've
got to do hit the subscribe button
what what are the other if any moments
from your early years that went into
shaping
the man you became was there anything
else because i i hear you in your books
and in your writing and your interviews
continue to cite that that
that sort of trauma with your father and
your stepfather then coming in and
and being the way that he was but there
was was there anything up leading until
you know your twenties that you cite as
being pivotal
and who you became yeah when i joined
the british
military i joined the army at the age of
16.
i'm just going on to 17. and i came from
a background
of french culture you know i'd go out
and drink coffee when i was 14 play
bowling when i was 15.
you know and all of a sudden i get
thrown into a male dominant organization
um the culture drinking fighting you fit
in or you [ __ ] off
it's as simple as that so what do you do
you try and fit in
but when you try and put a a round peg
into a square hole
you know you're going to get stuck and
you either stay stuck
okay you and you go around pleasing
everyone else or you pull yourself out
of that situation
and that's ultimately what i've done
with the army i spent four years in the
army then left
because of that situation it wasn't me i
wasn't this aggressive
young lad that loved drinking i'd never
used to drink
i was always polite always respectful
i'd walk past someone i'd tip my hat
you know in france you said bonjour and
you know you just have a little chat you
do that in england
when when i was 16 17 walking past
someone nodding and they're like what
the [ __ ] are you looking at
no it used to shock me and i used to
think i'm only saying hi mate what you
know
and that was a pivotal four years in my
life where i thought to myself
can i fit in to this uk culture
um or i can
pull myself out of it and for the first
four years i found myself fitting in
and i found myself being good at
drinking i found myself being good at
fighting
i found myself being good at being a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know because that's what i needed to
be to fit in so
again those were demons
that i discovered along the way that i
found that i was good at so would i let
anyone
take the piss out of me anymore you bet
no because you're going to get you're
going to get good hiding
you know would i would i go out and and
drink and fit in yeah of course of
course i would you know
hey one of the lads i want to fit in i
mean i'm so
i'm so far detached from all of that but
if i'm this young polite respectful
sort of multiculturaled individual then
that's gonna be a more of a hindrance
moving forward in in what i need to do
especially in the military then it is
uh a benefit so you find yourself
turning into this person i can just
remember
i was about 21 and
i went to macedonia and i worked with
the french foreign legion
out there because i speak fluent french
and i worked with the french friend
legion a bit and i saw how they were
they're very
very mature very sort of you know
going back to that french culture you
know they're all family orientated very
i thought to myself wow this is this is
who i am
and when i got back off that tour i can
just remember going to the squadron bar
i was in nine parachute squadron wall
engineers going to the squadron bar
we've just done a six-month tour i'm
going to the squadron bar and i remember
walking in there and i remember seeing
someone
um a staff sergeant probably about 35
36 you know i'm a young 20 21 year old
drinking from a a boot for an old desert
boot
right and he's drinking piss being
drinking piss from my boot and i can
just remember looking at him thinking
if i continue the way that i'm going
that's going to be me
in 15 years time and it scared the hell
out of me
i can remember just thinking i've got to
get the hell out of here i walked out of
that bar
and the next day i put my notice in i
was like that this is not who i
am this is not you know i've gained more
demons
from this four years than i have
any friends any benefits from it
and that was a pivotal point that was a
pivotal point in my life where i thought
to myself wow
you know i can either go i can have a
change in such a way
and just be stuck in this square hole
or i can pull myself out rebuild on the
foundations that i have of knowing that
i'm a good person
and you and from there you handed in
your notice and what happened next
from there i handed him my notice and
and i left and
um i found that
in civvie street i was acting
the person that i never wanted to be in
the military right
but i'd found that that had followed me
that that had taken
charge of me give me be specific those
demons that um
those demons that had sort of identified
themselves within that four years were
running the show
so when i got out i joined the
metropolitan police
and i was acting like a proper squaddie
right now going out drinking every night
you know
cheating on my exams um drink driving
you know i got all the way through
training a couple of weeks ago
a couple of weeks to go passed all the
tests i got caught drink driving
boom kicked out the um kicked out the
met
um out the training um in hendon
and but it didn't bother me i was like
yeah you know once a soldier always a
soldier
and i was living in the past and being
someone who
completely wasn't me but who had control
of me
and then getting into into the street
life
you know i got into the street life
where you know
fighting not gangs not games but that
that social circle where you know you
have to uphold a reputation where you
and the one thing that you know well
i'll say the one thing but the thing i
was good at that
fitted me is that was a good scrapper i
knew i know how to scrap i know how to
drink
and how to fight but you find yourself
reverting back to the person
who you never wanted to be and i suppose
that was the defense mechanism
i knew that that worked in the uk i'd
never tried and tested anything else
as soon as i came over to the uk
straight into the military again now i
spent
10 12 years in france before that then
boom
straight over into into the british
culture and i thought that that's how
you acted
i never knew what silly street was about
because
um i never i was never in it so um it
took me a
a good couple of years again
to realize what saved you what pulled
you out of the job
there's one moment that saved me um
i refused to sign on i refuse to take
any any help from the government same um
and i can remember my auntie i was
living with my auntie at the time and
you've got
you know you've got no money what are
you going to do i said well i'm going to
go down to the job center why won't you
just sign on
you know until you find a job i'm like
no
that was proud i was like no i've never
taken a penny off the government
i thought now i'm going to go to the job
center i remember walking into the job
center walking up the stairs walking
into the job center
and i had my red book and the red book
when you leave the military it's got all
your
all your qualifications military
qualifications all your credentials
and i walked into the job center and the
guy obviously recognized the books
they'd probably have
hundreds of people going there you know
a year and he said oh mate you're x
military on yourself yeah he said come
to the desk he sat down with me and
he opened up my book and he started
reading my book
and he looked up at me and he said why
did you leave the military
and before i could answer i was going to
say something back and he said
i have hundreds of these come across my
desk and they said this is one of the
best reports i've ever read
he said so my advice to you as he
slammed the book shot he went
went go back into that space and i
remember just sitting there
um i was 22 sitting down and thinking
mike okay he's gonna offer me a job now
and he just
handed me the book and called over the
next person and i was just like
i'm picking up a bit to myself guys
you know but obviously there's there's
all military qualifications there's
nothing for me out there apart from to
empty bins or whatever it may be
and i remember taking the book and as i
walked down the steps of the job center
i sat down halfway down on the steps
and i had a train ticket in my pocket
and probably about
a couple of quid loose change that's
that was my life
um this was at the age of 22 23 maybe
and um and i can just remember thinking
to myself
right why the hell are you sat
skin nothing in your life
apart from what you the clothes that
you're wearing and what's in your
pockets
jobless and then
a moment of clarity just hit me it's
almost as if i had an out of body
experience and i was looking back at the
boys sitting on the step and
i just remember thinking to myself right
i'll tell you why
it's because you're pretending to be
someone else
you're lying to yourself therefore
you're living a lie
you're you know you think you're better
than everyone else
you know you've got this reputation that
you want to uphold that's not you
um you're just you're just a shadow of
who you really are
you're not you know who the hell do you
think you are
because the person that i'm looking at
you know almost looking in the mirror
the person that i'm looking at
is exactly where you should be sat on a
[ __ ] step
jobless with nothing because
this isn't you and if you want to live
in the shadow if you want to
stay stuck in that hole in that square
hole
then keep lying to yourself and keep
living a lie
and that moment i'll always go back to
that moment whenever i get a bit above
myself
or a bit too big for my boots i always
go back to that moment where i ripped
myself apart
because it freed me as an individual and
i promise you this and it's not
cliche this isn't some kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] story that i'm telling
you it freed me as an individual because
i can remember remember standing up
on them steps feeling like a new man
because
i just identified who i was this isn't
you get that out your life get out of
your life get that out of your life
be you and i had those foundations to
fall back on
because i knew who i was ultimately but
it was discovered and and
yeah ego covered with so much [ __ ]
covered with so much complications that
i'd
implemented on myself and when i got rid
of it all
i was just like that you know what i was
good at the military
i've got best recruit best pt when i was
in the army you know what i'm gonna do i
love that lifestyle but it's just around
the wrong people
i was in the wrong regiment you know i'm
gonna rejoin the military
but i'm going to be a team player i'm
going to be myself i'm going to be this
respectful gentleman hard worker that i
know that i am
which i mean i'm not going to go out
boozing i'm not going to go out fighting
i'm not going to try and fit in
you know if they don't accept me for who
i am then so be it
the military obviously isn't for me i
joined the royal marines i went straight
down the careers office
straight down the careers office and
joined the royal marines and within a
couple of months because of my previous
um military uh history um i got him very
quick
and within a couple of months i found
myself going through royal marine
training
and when i passed out of war marine
training i got um awarded with best
recruit which is the king's badge
and i can just remember thinking to
myself right and you've been here before
you know you've got best recruit best pt
you know you rested on your laurels went
to your unit didn't really fit in
you're in the same position now now you
can either use this
as a positive and push forward and and
you know go on to achieve great
things or you can try and fit in
booze fight be a be a
camp hero you know a pub soldier
and just be back to square one where you
was
five six seven years ago there's
something and i want to carry on from
that story but just going back to that
i find it super fascinating that you're
sat on those stairs
and at a moment when your ego kind of
dissolves because of the circumstances
you find yourself in
um you're actually able then to go and
pursue your true self and i find
you know i had someone sat in this chair
previously and he's the biggest investor
in the world in psychedelics
and one of the things that he talks
about with psychedelics is it what it
does is it strips back the [ __ ]
your ego the the identity you've been
living to please society
and what's left is like who you actually
are and it's and it's so funny that
so many of the guests i speak to and
some of the psychologists i've spoken to
talk about
in order to like find your happiness and
pursue your true self you have to get
rid of that [ __ ] and
what i'm what i was hearing when you
were saying that is you know you'd you'd
create this reputation an identity
for yourself which actually was leading
you astray but it was helping you
survive in those circles
absolutely and this tough tough decision
to say do you know i'm going to break
out that circle
leave that identity behind throw myself
into an uncertain moment and go in
pursuit of like who i actually am
and everybody faces that in their life
you know as a
kid growing up in devon in a school of
1500 white kids
pretending that i liked indie music and
pretending i was to fit in and survive
yeah and i i left the city because i
deep down in my heart i didn't resonate
with anybody
but i was in that small town city
surrounded by 1500 white kids that liked
the kooks
yeah and then 18 i was like i'm out here
i'm gonna go be steve move to manchester
you know and i dropped and i started to
and i think everybody in their life
regardless of what walk of life you
you face that decision and either you've
realized that you're living an identity
or a life untrue to yourself
and you've gone on the journey to go
find yourself or right now as you're
listening to this
you are and you'll know it yeah because
the words that you've described there
will ring true
so that completely i completely
understand that and that makes complete
sense to me
and one of the things that i say um is
the most courageous thing you can do
above all bravery is
to be honest with yourself why is that
so hard these days
i had one day last week was actually
sunday
where i didn't have my heel and i had a
little bit of junk food and i don't know
what it is
but i think my body has got used to
eating clean food because for the next
three days i felt i still kind of feel
what day we are now tuesday i still kind
of feel
crap from the junk food that i i just
had one drunk meal i had this junk meal
right
i still feel crap now i don't know what
it is i think my body has genuinely got
used to eating good food so the minute
now that i put in something that is bad
for me my body goes steve what are you
doing
um and i felt bad for the last two days
and i've returned to huell and i feel
good again this is just an anecdotal
story but i said this to my pa last
night
i said i for some reason having now
transitioned to a
really good diet on your any sort of um
dabble with the
the stuff that i used to eat is more
sort of alarming to my body
and i notice it way more than i ever had
so yeah you know
it's one thing having a podcast sponsor
that pays you money but
it's another thing having a podcast
sponsor who
you genuinely believe can help people
change their lives for the better
one of the things that i say um is the
most courageous thing you can do
above all bravery is
to be honest with yourself why is that
so hard these days
you know people say to me and you know
what's the bravest thing you've ever
done and i always talk about the story
of the job center steps because that
took courage that took
balls that that's bravery right there
you know i've been in rooms where
bullets are flying over my head i've
kicked doors down and you know
i've taken i've saved life it's like
that's not
being brave that's just me being
extremely good at my job and loving what
i do
you know it's not there's nothing to do
with bravery you know bravery is almost
forced upon you
but when you decide to step into the
arena when you decide to step
into that and go right i'm going to face
this
and put that mirror on yourself
ultimately
facing yourself that is the hardest but
most liberating thing i've ever done
and people shy away from that and they
live in the void
they live this life where they're just
living the void i call it and say you're
on autopilot
because you're lying to yourself and
it's pretty simple therefore you're
going to live a lie i don't care
it's i'm not the archbishop of
canterbury you know i'm like
i'm not a rocket scientist it's just
simple science you know if you lie to
yourself
guess what you're going to live a lie um
but standing in a mirror standing in the
mirror
and ripping yourself apart
does take away all the [ __ ] and all
the complications and it frees you as an
individual
but it's you have to do it on a regular
basis you can't just go i've done it
once so here we go i've found myself
this is who i am because
hopefully you're constantly changing
you're constantly evolving you're
constantly
um adapting your mindset you know that's
what evolution is about you know the the
world is designed to
to you know is is it evolutionizes and
we are designed to do exactly the same
and the moment
that you you're not honest with yourself
this game over for you it's like it's
like you do you just want to be
just that person you know like a lot of
people say to me and
you know i've remember you remember me
from the military i'm like yeah yeah
yeah they got [ __ ] i you've changed a
lot
you've changed i'm like that i haven't
seen you for 10 years
i hope i've changed and i say to them
you haven't that's why you're still just
that guy
that's why i'm at middleton and you're
still just that guy
is because of course i've changed i'd
like to think in another 10 years time
when you see me that
i've changed again because if i haven't
i'm doing something wrong
and that doing something wrong is not
being honest with myself
and it all goes back to you as an
individual no one can do that for you
no one can do that for you and i say to
every everyone
everything starts with you and it's
it's so true if you don't want to change
nothing will change around you
you know if you don't want to be honest
with yourself well guess what you're
lying to yourself
it's a complete opposite therefore
you're living a lie it's like you have
to do this on a
on a on a weekly on a monthly basis any
time
an obstacle was thrown in front of you
you couldn't
fall back on right to be honest with
yourself be honest with who you are
be honest with with with you you know
with how you tackle things and
and and don't lie to yourself the cost
of being yourself and being honest with
yourself
is it seemingly increasing in this day
and age and
you know i find it i think that's a
really really valid point one that i
hadn't
i didn't think expressed properly which
is you had that reflective moment when
you sat on those stairs where you say
[ __ ] it we're gonna start being honest
with ourselves but then especially as
you get more successful
you know in your media career and
everything else the forces
at play trying to get you to not be
honest with yourself
get greater and greater and this is this
crazy sort of
i don't know paradox or whatever we see
in society at the moment which is
you being honest with yourself is the
reason you're sat here it's the reason
you're at middleton yeah
but and that's what's made you go
explode right
but then the higher you get it's like i
don't know
you know the the resistance for you not
to be yourself becomes greater because
now you've got now you're more of a
target right
hard [ __ ] hard [ __ ] life to live
do you know what i've
been witness of it you know the council
culture
the um don't say that ant because you
will lose this book deal
you will lose that media career you will
lose that production
and witness of it right now you know um
i hear it
probably on a weekly basis um
but then that's that square peg
round hole it's like no i don't
you know it's it's every time i think
about that
and i always have two principles
with everything that i do is
don't go out to offend so i don't say
things to offend people
therefore they choose to be offended i
don't say things to offend people i just
say things what i think is right was
what served me um good in my experiences
and my career my mindset
and the second thing is you know don't
don't do
things maliciously so first of all don't
go out
it's it's verbal and also actions
you know don't don't do things
maliciously because then
ultimately yeah you're going to have a
backlash you're going to have a reaction
to
to to what you've done um so that's
exactly what i do i don't go out to
offend
but i go out to tell the truth but i
also go out to seek
the truth you know and i go out to
seeking the truth again everything
starts with you and with who i am
it's dangerous and it's it's it's
definitely in the social media area
it's dangerous it is dangerous but
hopefully you get past that
that stage of people realizing that
actually this is ant he's
not been any different he's not you know
voiced
anything different he's not tried to fit
into a media agenda he's not trying to
try to blag anyone he's not being fake
this is who aunt middleton is
and he will always be like that
regardless yeah regardless but then
there's that
platform of not reaching that level
quite yet
and then everything descending upon you
um and i and unfortunately there's a lot
of people out there that are scared to
say what they
truly feel are scared to voice their
opinions uh
scared to you know voice their values
because
ultimately it takes food off the table
it's a career stopper when your career
stops guess what suffers after that your
family
and then when that when that suffers
guess what there's not much out there
for you
you have to rebuild again well all those
10 15
20 years career that you've you've built
all for that one moment is it worth it
no so what do you do
keep quiet what'd you do don't do
anything
just say what they want you to say and
do what they want you to do
that doesn't [ __ ] rub with me that's
a sore point with me
you know you try and you try and make me
someone that i'm
that i'm not like i've been made someone
them than i'm that i'm not
you're probably gonna get even you feel
gonna get the worst out of me
even more so because everything comes
back around to who you
truly are they're trying to control you
yeah it's a controlling measure
and it's like listen i've i've let
people control my life i've let
situations control my life
and it's i've ended up psychologically
not physically
psychologically on that brink of
questioning who the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] am
i who am i
that's what i question and the moment i
start questioning who am i
then i know that project isn't for me i
know that that
that sponsor isn't for me i know that
that tv
um channel or that tv production isn't
for me
because the moment that comes into
question and it's like you
don't probably don't get who i am you
probably don't understand who i am you
probably haven't done your homework with
who i am
do i fit into your agenda and it's like
if you don't fit into one agenda
you get bounced boom straight across to
the opposite side
right it's like listen i don't belong on
that side it's just cause i don't
believe
in in this this side doesn't mean i
belong on that side
yeah i'm i belong in the middle you know
people say
you are you on the left you're on the
right i'm like i'm not on the left or
right i'm in the
middle i'm in the middle
you say slightly something that goes
against this agenda then again you just
get
bounced straight to the other side the
right road i don't recognize you the
left won't recognize you so there's who
are your enemies of both
yeah but it's it's and it's a dangerous
place to live in this is
it's it's it
it's it's a sad state of affairs a real
sad
sad um sad state of affairs and
you know just because your values and
your views are different doesn't mean my
message isn't
isn't the same you know my message
everything that i do
is about positivity it's about mindset
it's about bringing people together you
look at sas who dares wins what does it
do
makes people realize what they're
capable of makes them find themselves it
brings people together
brings families together you know mutiny
teamwork brings people together escape
you know
straight talking being honest and open
and and
it makes it makes you feel good it
brings you together it unites people
because they can be open and honest with
themselves and therefore they know what
they're capable of
self belief starts to kick in and they
feel good about it's bringing people
together
right and that is you'd be inhumane
really to to not think like that to not
want to help people out to not want to
so the message is is is always the same
but it's this bit
in the middle right don't you ever get
pushed to one side
you can't have this sort of in the
middle opinion of well actually my
values are the same as yours
you know i'm all about positive change
yeah okay
so what why are you saying my values
don't fit with yours because i'm about
positive change look at my message for
the last
five six years since i've been in the
media it's positive change
unity look at what i do everything i do
whether it's my books my tours
my tv programs everything is about
bringing people together
bringing the best out of people so
just because this in-between bit i my
views are different and mine are
probably truthful
which people don't want to hear the
truth it's like right bounce off to one
side and then and then you start to get
cancelled but
what's the answer though like so i i you
know i hear we've heard pierce morgan
talk a lot about this as well and other
people talk about how
you know if you don't perfectly fit the
the views or the perfect hashtag of the
of the left or whatever then um you're
basically being cancelled in culture and
i i genuinely
this is a [ __ ] probably the most
genuine question i've ever asked in this
podcast because it's one that i'm
thinking about all the time
is i also see this happening my views
don't always fit the left or the right
and sometimes like in the black lives
matter moment
i posted on my instagram saying it was
actually my best performing post of all
time
i said because there was this whole
narrative around like silence is
violence and if you're not saying
anything then you're a racist
i did a post saying like that's
obviously [ __ ] yeah as i said it's
unpopular black opinion
if someone doesn't post a black square
on their instagram doesn't make them a
racist
people process things in completely
different in fact the most unnatural
reaction to trauma
is to take to social media so like and
that absolutely it was
it was it didn't fit the like silences
violence narrative
and and my ability and i like of course
that's [ __ ] true
like i mean it doesn't it doesn't fit i
understand
right but it's no one not one individual
in the millions and millions of views
that that posted
could tell me there was one slide in
that nine that was
they disagreed with but it was the
feeling
that i wasn't wearing the football kit
of the of the left that made some people
go
you're an awful person to sleep and then
i'd go why they'd go
yeah yeah exactly you see their minds
ticking and ticking you're like
tell me tell me what's wrong with the
post they go oh you know what sorry
yeah and and i i i think well i'm i know
i'm not going to change
so when i look into my future i go at
some point i'm going to get cancelled
because my brand is building i've got
some stuff coming up on
in the media and i'm thinking i know i'm
not going to change so
what's the answer here like i'm always
going to and i know that it's getting
more
is the answer this is why you're here
yeah
i know it's like it's like it's like
what the answer is to be true to who you
are yeah and just take the intention
and it's like it's you know that's the
one thing i've always fall back on
is just knowing you know if you're an
idiot you know if you're irritating
people you know if you're not a good
person
and then ultimately you know you're
going to get what's coming to you and
you probably deserve it
but i know that i'm a good person i know
my foundations i'm polite and respectful
you know i don't go out to offend ever
go out to offend i hate confrontation
because of the way that i know that i
can deal with confrontation it frightens
me
to get into that situation because i
know what i'm capable of
okay so i don't ever i'm over polite i'm
over respectful
because i think people should be treated
like that now i like to be treated like
that i wasn't treated like that when i
started off in my army career and i know
what it feels like okay and i never
would never want anyone to
to experience that so i'm over polite
and i'm over respectful
and i've always fall back on that i
always look at myself in the mirror and
i go and
you're you i know i'm a good person and
that
are the foundations that i've built
that's my foundations that's
who i am okay so you can knock my bricks
down
i will but guess what i will keep
building and building and building
and you can knock it even if you knock
them down to the foundations
i can fall back on being true to myself
and there's no more liberating steve
liberating feeling than that of being
true to who you are going do you know
what
i'm not going to fit into that agenda
i'm not going to fit into that box
i'm not going to squeeze myself in there
to make myself feel uncomfortable
for your agenda because that's not who i
am would you rather lose at all yeah 100
because i've got my foundations i've got
my foundations i will always
build steve always build and this part
of the building
is so high now that can you cancel me
crack on because i guarantee you i just
keep building this side this side of
this side decide
because the people that know me know who
i am
and someone said this to me with all the
stuff that's been going on lately
um you know i've had some sponsors i've
cancelled i've had some
tv programs that i've kind of crack on
but the people that by my side the
sponsors
and the channels and the production
companies that by my side that have
worked for me saying and
we have the privilege of knowing you and
that wrong accord to me though
i'm like they have the privilege of
knowing me
and i think to myself wow you've got the
privilege of knowing i've got the
privilege of knowing myself
because i know who i am and i'm glad i'm
glad i gave you that privilege
and it's not being big headed i'm glad i
gave you that privilege of knowing me
because you know that this is just a
storm of words
you know that this is just media hype
you know this is just fake news you know
this isn't real you know
yeah i've maybe got a little bit of a
fiery side to me but you know
you're getting that with me you know i'm
rough around the edges
so yeah and i'm happy to you know to to
to cut a few of the edges but
those edges are still going to be there
do you know what i mean
so when they said that to me and it's
something that will stick with me
forever and it's
from a very very good sponsor you know
um
very much to do with my books and i can
just
and i remember sitting back and just
taking that breath and going
keep doing what you're doing then you're
doing the right thing and then this last
week
you know so many doors have opened
production companies calling me
channels calling me um
you know and you hear about it you hear
about oh you know you get cancelled then
that's your career done and
but then you've got your peers morgan's
you've got your your jeremy clarkson's
and
now you've got your aunt middleton's
okay and
it just goes to show that i'm doing the
right thing and that actually yeah i'm
not gonna fit i'm not gonna be
comfortable with
with everyone and i'm not gonna be their
cup of tea well that's fine because
guess what
i don't want to work with you if i get
questioned one little bit about my
who i am like i said before if i get
questioned one little bit about who i am
by any brands
any sponsors any channels then i will
not work with them
i will say listen thank you very much
it's obviously
you know not the right match um
you go on and do your thing and i'll go
on and do my thing because i will always
go on and do my thing
and that building can completely drop to
the foundations
but when you're honest with yourself and
you know who you are
those foundations are solid you will
always have something to build from
but when you're not honest with yourself
and everything comes crumbling down and
you have no foundations to fall on
you're [ __ ] that's when you're in
trouble that's when you start to go well
i won't say that i won't act like this i
won't do this and i won't do that
and that's when you become someone else
that's when you become fake to who you
are
and guess what desperate times then
you're like a wounded animal
and guess what you're probably going to
be right at the back of the pack
for the rest of your life the
psychological impact of living a life
that isn't true to yourself and
i mean this is why people have these
like midlife crises when they've even in
like
the professional world where they've you
know their mum and dad have told them to
go and be a
whatever a banker or a lawyer they don't
want to be they want to be a [ __ ]
dancer or whatever
and then they get mid-life crisis and
you look at throughout psychology i talk
about this a little bit my book
you know if you look at certain
communities like the lgbtq
community their suicide rates are so so
high amongst those groups because a lot
of them have been
oppressed in a way where they can't live
their true life they can't be their
identity so they've had to
live a lie that's live a fake life and
then you see suicide rates go up because
that is a form of torture
and this is when i asked you the
question about you know would you rather
lose at all
um one would one would actually maybe
even if i question myself say well
what are you losing yeah if you're
losing tv shows and you're losing things
that aren't true to yourself
is it a loss you know it's not a loss
because
you will always find something that fits
you dude i mean if you have the passion
and the drive and
the ambition and the positivity
of knowing who you are and ultimately
the world is your oyster
it's like you know people have this
impression of me that i'm this
hard-faced drill sergeant
non-accepting person i am the complete
opposite go and be the [ __ ] you want to
be that's my message
if that's what then don't let anyone
force you into
into saying anything doing anything or
being anyone else be yourself
but this is the side that people don't
see of you and this
but this is my personal side steve i
people see what they want to see the
media will write what they want to write
they will they will make you
they will make you out to be who they
want you to be
but you can't put all of that into a
hashtag you've got to characterize
yourself in 10 letters yeah and this is
the problem with with
issues that are complex and nuanced and
there's different layers and
you if it doesn't fit into a hashtag
then and this is the football team
analogy as well
quick interjection before we get back to
the podcast just want to say that as you
know because i've talked about it a few
times on this podcast
i'm probably one of the biggest users in
the world of a website called fiverr.com
f i v e r r dot com
i use it for everything whether it's my
podcast or whether it's my personal
brand content whether it's my business
or other projects that i'm doing
and this week i've used it again i've
used it to make a website called katana
which is my investment company
people don't know this my old company
was called social chain and katana or
katana
is the italian word for chain that's the
inspiration keep that to yourself
um but it's just another example of how
you can use fiverr to help you
expand your capabilities as an
entrepreneur as a content creator
and i've managed to get a website up for
my investment company katana in the
space of
two and a half days and it cost me 400
quid
typically that would cost tens of
thousands of pounds and typically it
would take months
that's the power of fiverr allowing you
to quickly and affordably extend the
capabilities of your team
of your personal brand and achieve
things that you might not have been able
to otherwise
i want to talk though going back to your
you know when you started in the
military one thing i
find really interesting is the guy that
was running around drinking boozing
getting in trouble
for him then to go into the military and
pass with flying colours
is like a massive contradiction in my
mind i'm like one
appears to be a guy that's kind of out
of control the other one and and
seemingly lacking the appreciation of
authority and then the other guy is one
that's able to
do what he's told and follow orders and
and and how did you achieve such that's
what they want
that's what they need they need the
animal
on the battlefield they need
the aggression they need the violence
because ultimately on the battlefield
you counter violence
with extreme violence you know there's
zero tolerance to violence in sydney
street in society nowadays
you show any form of violence you can
end up behind bars been there
but in the military you you counter
violence with extreme violence you you
counter anger with extreme anger
and you're that's needed i i needed to
be that person on the battlefield i
needed to
to have to cut myself off from any
emotional sort of
feelings any emotional you know sort of
um
discrepancies because
they were the missions that i went on
now i was hunting down
taliban commanders you know i was
getting into [ __ ] [ __ ] storms to
firefights
every week every couple you know two
three times a week
i needed to put to call on those demons
to come to the forefront of who i was to
get the job done
and then switch it you're expected to
switch it because
one moment you're kicking the door down
you know
taking out enemy combatants the next
next door you're kicking the door down
there's
women and children in there so
you you live on that side or you live on
that side
and then when you get the two confused
you know you i might be in afghanistan
best man put me on camp you know
well you can't be doing that and well
what who the [ __ ] do you want
i mean you can't be doing that you can't
be you know getting into fights downtown
you can't be you know
getting you know i just get into a hell
of a lot of fights you know it can help
ruin my military career because you know
but then
three tours of afghanistan are done
almost back to back
perfect out there man boom boom boom
boom boom
so what what animal do you want you know
and it's okay to be able to flip from
one to the other when when you're here
but when you live on the complete
opposite sides of the spectrum
you're gonna get confused every now and
then you're going to be met with a
situation in society where
you're met with aggression you're met
with violence and this
demon takes over you know what it is is
it's a moment of madness it's just a
confusion confliction between the two
you know and it's between the two two
people and sometimes
it goes whack yeah and before you know
it that crossover
is too much they're both like trained to
survive but in different
environments in completely different
environments and sometimes those
environments
you know you're forced to act and those
environments get switched yeah and it's
literally like a flash in front of your
eyes it's like bang bang
[ __ ] i used the wrong person there i
used the wrong environment it's
it's and and that's that's the world
that i live in
that's the world that i lived in that
was my life that was
you know i used to come back from from
afghanistan
and you know i've got four four four
four children at home
i'm a fifth one from a previous
relationship who's 19 but um used to
come home
i remember coming back from afghanistan
and my daughter was born
she's 13 now my daughter was born um 10
days
before i left for a six-month tour in
afghanistan
so she was born so i didn't know her and
i came back six months later and she was
like nearly seven months um
and then i went straight on special
forces selection so for another six
months so i came back after like a year
really
of not really being at home to a to a
one-year-old daughter who
barely recognized me you know she would
push me away she would
you know and i'd interact and i'll be
playing dolls on
on the floor barbies and my wife came in
one day and
i was playing with these barbies and she
thought i'd lost the plot
she's like she's like you know got these
barbies together trying to make her
laugh trying to make her smile
because for the last year she's just
seen this pent up
war machine you know and i've come back
and i'm not
i'm not very easy to deal with you know
during those transitions you know i need
a bit of time
what do you mean by that you're not very
easy to deal with in those transitions
well you come back from
you can't just take a hit even though
i can do it i can take your head off put
a different head on
but that transition of
kicking doors down to being back with a
family i need
even now when i come back off of filming
when i come back i need
before we actually start getting on
again you know before i start settling
back into the into
into the family it takes about two weeks
and again me and my partner are the best
most compatible partners in the world
the teamwork that we have is
absolutely amazing you know hence why
i've been with her for 16 years been
married for
14. um but it still takes that two-week
period
for me of me breaking her her routine
of me coming in you know taking over
everything you know
with the kids taking taking the kids to
school taking ruining her
her life that she's built i come in like
a storm
and it takes two weeks before that storm
normally calms down and we go all right
you know
i cannot argue in to this but you know
just disagreements just
control issues can you know it's it's
like two worlds colliding right
and then after the two weeks as
everything settles i'm away again
i might be on tour i might be like i'm
in australia for two months now it's
like
so it's that constant communication or
that constant you know crossing over of
of worlds that you need to really sort
of mold together
and as my life is getting more and more
and i'm not in these high
octane situations i'm not in these life
or death situations
um it's becoming easier and easier
you talk you know i had actually a
military commando sat in in the seat as
well
who talked about his experiences and
when he came back from war he was
talking to me about the ptsd he suffered
and um just being around the house and
you know seeing the tin can stacked on
the shelf at home and
and like you know barking at his wife
because they weren't straight and things
like that and feeling that you know
feeling some of the disciplines of all
coming home with him
you i've seen you talk on this topic so
i know that
you know you've you've handled that in a
different way
but um what are some of the the things
that have come
come back with you from war that you
don't like
or that you think aren't helping you in
your in your personal life
um they're two different worlds
you know you deal with dark humor
dark banter to get you through certain
situations
and that dark humor and dark banter and
dark way of talking is a norm to you
because you live and breathe that and
sometimes that comes out you know
and only when i'm doing a military style
show
you know you you come out you might say
something which is a for me
probably a throwaway comment or a bit of
banter
then you realize there's a hundred of
crew members listening and there's
nothing
you know it just might be i might say
something about someone or my it's never
direct you know it's always an
indirect conversation that we have um
it's that military banter that i [ __ ]
hate sometimes i hear myself talking
like a military man and i hate it i
might say
military words hoofing honking was
you know there's loads of them out there
um and i think to myself why are you
talking like that
but it's just come it just comes out
because i might find myself in in a
high octane situation in a stressful
situation in a in an
aggressive situation and a violent
situation which which i revert back to
what i know works which is this
ultimately this military person
but then i think [ __ ] you know i'm not
in a military environment i'm not in in
in a i'm in society you know i've got
you know
and it's controlling that that i find
really difficult
um but knowing also acknowledging that
it needs to be controlled
you know i'm not in the military anymore
you know and i always hate this once a
marine
always a marine you know you get people
go hey once a marine always a marine i'm
like
i was a marine 12 years ago 10 years ago
you know now i'm i'm a media um tv
presenter
i'm now an extinguished author i'm now
you know
i like to say like you know about
mindset my mindset girl go around do my
tours you know i'm in a completely
different space but
i have to pull upon this young soldier
every now and then in order to get the
job done because i know that that works
you know i know that if i do that but i
just need to fine-tune it i need to
buffer it around the edges which again
is a work in progress you know i i put
my hands up when i go [ __ ] hell do
you know what i mean
yeah i shouldn't have said that i
shouldn't have done that you know and
i'm the first one to admit it
but people have to realize that listen
it's it's
it's a work in progress it's not
something i can change overnight
you need to understand me you need to
understand who i am
um in order to to acknowledge that okay
well [ __ ] hell yeah that was a bit
uncomfortable to see some of the things
that we do with the recruits
you know they're like [ __ ] you know and
she's like he's on on his knees and
you're
you're literally you know saying to him
that you stay there
you know if you think you're not worthy
you know if you if you're a piece of
[ __ ] blah blah blah
but it's hard for people to see that and
to watch that but ultimately there's
always a
positive motivator behind that so
that's where people i think get get
confused is like negativity is a great
fuel it's a great source to use to get
to where you need to be
but only if there's a positive motivator
ahead of it
so you can't use negativity to get
through a situation
if there's not a positive motivator
because
all you'll do is you'll feel off in the
negative lane because there's no
positive motivators to aim towards it's
like a plow
like i say the plow is is the positive
motivator
and the fuel is the negative with
aggression whether it's
revenge whether it's you know prove
people wrong whether it's you know these
are all things that
that that fuel you but you
be sure that there's always a positive
motivator so when i'm
talking like that to the recruits what
i'm doing it's believe it or not
to get the best out of them to make them
realize what they're capable of make
them
bring their attributes and and and um
personality to the forefront so they can
identify who they are
and a lot of people they bring that to
the forefront or i fit that mirror on
them and they look at themselves and
they go oh
[Music]
no i don't like what i see they vw or
they go or they leave yeah so that's
what i was going to say it's also a
filter it's a filter
and that's what a selection process is
and that's but that's how i it's not
only what selection process is that's
how i live my life steve
i'm i'm so brutally honest with what i
do in
situations i find myself in
and the environment that that i choose
to be in is it
and it's that brutal honesty it's that
brutal
sort of truth
that the motivator is always becoming a
better version of who you are of
of learning something growing from it
and becoming a better version of who you
were yesterday
and how important is it to take personal
responsibility for your outcomes in life
because there's a
growing culture of blame and you know
victimhood
and i see this as well as someone that
um you know the
the best thing that probably happened to
me is
if i was successful and i had parents
that were rich and i had loads of money
and i got a degree and
i got these great grades people would
immediately go well no steve can't tell
us anything because he got to hand it to
him
fortunately i was the opposite i'm a
black kid born in africa
kicked out of school dropped out of
university after one lecture got no
degree
parents are bankrupt so i can talk a
little bit more about like
personal responsibility without being
discredited people say oh well of course
you [ __ ] say that and like yeah
but i see this growing culture because i
was a kid in moscow in manchester
stealing pizzas to feed myself only i
don't know seven eight years ago
and i know that my mindset and the
the behavior that my mindset created is
the reason i'm sat here now
like of course there's luck timing i
understand that but my mindset
increased my probability of being sat
here now so when i preach that to people
especially people that don't want to
take take personal responsibility or
like
you know victimhood or blame keeps them
nice and safe and comfortable and it
means they don't have to look in the
mirror
yeah they go vague [ __ ] you [ __ ] you guy
but it's hard to attack me it's hard to
attack me because what you're going to
say
yeah you know what privilege i had the
privilege i had was moving to this
country as a baby
but that's a privilege privilege of
knowing who you are yeah so you can take
all that income
yeah yeah because they haven't got the
private privilege of knowing you
yeah right but you have the privilege of
knowing yourself because guess what
you've been there
you've done it you've got the t-shirt
you've been honest with yourself you you
you realize you know you realize your
mistakes you realize your areas of your
way you learn from failure you grow from
it you become a better version of who
you are so
that's what that's why i say that that
statement of we we have the privilege of
knowing you
is so powerful because ultimately that's
what you fall back on all the time
that's why you can take it that's why
you can take that
take that and you can it will bounce off
you just like that's your negativity
that's your
it's not nothing to do with me that's
that's you and it bounces off me like it
bounces off you
but the moment you step into that victim
mentality
that's when you feel that the world owes
you everything that's when you feel like
that you know
why is he why is he where he is and i'm
not there
why has he got this and i haven't got
this why oh
right well i could quite happily
go back and not be cancelled
okay for example if i went guys yeah
really really sorry about that but i
suffered from a bit from ptsd you know
the death of my father you know
it's it's like [ __ ] hell it's
it's like one i don't suffer from ptsd
how many times have i had that thrown at
me
steve going and if you say you suffer
from ptsd who can question
that well no one can question it
actually wait wait there's one person
that can question it
me because i haven't got [ __ ] ptsd
well no no no
no you haven't but if you say that then
you know the papers will do this
the um the the courts will do this
people will start to go oh well actually
you know
the stuff that he's been through and
he's seen he's done he's witnessed yeah
of course listen throw him another bone
give him another chance
i feel sorry for him [ __ ] that
jeremy and it's like when i went to
prison i left the military
went to prison got into a violent
violent altercation
yep violence on violence of course put
my hand up 100
i'll do my time my lawyer said to me and
do you want to go to prison i was like
of course i don't want to go to prison
who wants to go to prison
he said well listen he is you're out he
went
say you've got ptsd if you say you got
ptsd
he said i guarantee you that's what he
said to me guarantee you
you will not go to prison you'll get
suspended sentence you'll have to go and
do a couple of courses
um and then you'll be at home with the
family
and i had four kids and a and a wife
actually at the time i had two children
and a wife at home that relied on me
i couldn't lie to myself i thought
don't get me wrong i'm not gonna lie to
you i thought to myself do you know what
that sounds appealing because who can
tell me that i haven't got ptsd
but then the question always goes back
to you because only you hold the answer
steve only you have that answer only i
knew that answer
i could lie to myself and live a lie and
[ __ ] knows where i'll be now
right i might be a bloody ptsd
with a counselor i might be you know but
i would have gone down that road
for years right so i've got two years
suspended since
two years of going down a road that
wasn't me going down that road of pure
lies every step i took wouldn't be a
true one
i always say to people people will mould
you and direct you in life
you know that's what people are there
for good people anyway they try and mold
but if that first footstep that you take
is not a true one
i said do not take it and the only
person that knows that
is you and i always
always always go back to that do i feel
comfortable taking this footstep
yes i do the rest of the world doesn't
well guess what
i feel comfortable doing it but yeah but
that she he's gonna have something to
say about it
she's gonna have something to say about
they're gonna have something to say
about it
i don't care is it true to me go back to
who i am
yeah boom i take it and i deal with
whatever comes at me because it can
bounce off me right because
as we spoke about it's like it's like we
know who we are we know what we're about
we know we know we're good people
so i'm willing to take that bang bang
bang and it does steve it does
literally bounce off me but also it when
it does get into me
because the moment it starts you know
when it gets over it does get into you
once i sit down and process it it fuels
me
i feel like thanos you know it's like
it's just like because i'm being true to
who i am and all this negative and i'm
thinking right just
just boom because guess what i preach
positivity till it comes home i
everything i believe is down to a
positive mindset and how you perceive
the way that you think um and the way
you know we have this default mindset
which is negative you know everything's
like what if this what if that won't do
that because of this and mine's the
opposite mind's like
right the best outcome is this this if
anything comes along i deal with it
okay and it's that mindset that i always
always fall back on and it's and
again it's it's one of those i just find
so liberating that i can just
just think that way but i put myself in
the firing line
i put myself constantly in the firing
line to constantly challenge myself
to constantly flip these negatives into
positives without
negativity you wouldn't have positivity
it wouldn't exist
it doesn't you know it's a polar
opposite so people say
so i challenge negativity i love
negativity because i will challenge it
and challenge it and challenge it i love
the work ethic and the psychological
sort of resilience it takes to challenge
negativity
there's a lot of people that negativity
comes and they ignore it or they bat it
off they run away
but the moment you dig into it and you
dig into it and you dig and it takes
time
it takes time as well isn't it it tests
you right and you dig into it and
all of a sudden you see a little light
you see a little glimpse of positivity
and that's all you're looking for is
that one little seed you grab that
boom bank that and then you grow that
seed until you find the next one
and there's nothing more rewarding in
this world than
flipping a negative into a positive
because if you're willing
and again if you're willing to work hard
enough and you're willing to take the
[ __ ] and the [ __ ]
uh and the [ __ ] and everything that
surrounds negativity if you're willing
to
dive into the center of it and you're
willing to work
in order to flip it into a positive then
i guarantee
you you you will find a positive in it
and i guarantee you that would be the
most rewarding thing you ever do
it's like failure it's exactly the same
with failure i look at failure and it's
just
it's like a challenge to me it's like
you can't do that and you don't know
nothing about that you're going to fail
at that
well listen i'll tell you what i
probably will fail at it but i'm not
scared to commit because i know that the
moment i commit to failure
i take two or three or four steps into
failure and i might go yeah
i haven't achieved that but those three
or four steps i've taken
that that's that's what i bank those
moments in the moment
that's what i bank a lot of people they
they might take on failure and they
might
fail their objective and they think oh i
failed that therefore i'm a failure
and they forget how far they've come
that this is completely automatically
written off
because they're going oh i failed that
mean it's like yeah i won't
go near that again that becomes part of
your identity i'm a failure i'm a
failure
yeah so they anytime failures that they
think their safety bubble
or victim but whatever they won't go
anywhere near it but i love it
when negativity comes along and failure
comes along
you know i'm so intrigued on what i'll
get out of it i'm so intrigued what i
learned from it
because when you learn you grow when you
grow you become a better version of who
you are
it's just that it's that knock-on effect
that it has and failure is exactly that
failure isn't going anywhere i found up
to now in my life i'm gonna fail to the
day i die
so you so you so you every single one of
you in here
is gonna fail whether you like it or not
it is everyday part of life as much as
it is breathing
it's surrounded by us so why do we
ignore it if it's part of
who we are and part of part of part of
what's what makes the world tick
then why don't we use it to our
advantage because the perceived cost of
failure
whatever that might be you know jenny at
work is going to think i'm not so
whatever and this person is going to
write this about me
the perceived cost especially in the
short term feels greater
it feels and that's the same force of
like the pc brigade or
that you know it's like it's better just
to stay in your lane today
and to just like put your head down be
quiet because
people think and this is the where it's
wrong people think
that's the safest place to be reflecting
on my own journey when i went to
university
and i knew that i this was a piece of
[ __ ] and that i needed to quit if i was
actually gonna become an entrepreneur
like it's calling my mom and then
telling her i'm dropping out and her
telling me never to speak to her again
right that was the resistance that was
the moment where life goes
stay in your [ __ ] lane right yeah but
when
people get you were so you were so and
then you're
but my brain was so clear the biggest
risk the biggest failure
would have been staying in university
and living a life not true to myself
some people
people say oh you're so you have so much
courage courage would have been staying
yeah
right and i think that's the that's the
thing of course my mom says i'd never
speak to me again and i don't speak to
her for two years
but look at the upside of living my even
if i'd failed like look at the upside of
being myself and i think that's
pretty much what i'm hearing from what
you're saying is like there's this you
know
the there is the short time resistance
where it's like oh my god if you fail
you're going to lose it all so i know
you'll lose it all if you don't try
exactly how the thing about it is the
way that your mindset thinks then it is
it's not a complicated way of thinking
it's like it's it's so simple really
so simple stupid that it's almost
incomprehendable
um and everything that i do and
you just said it then and make what you
just said that makes complete sense to
me
every single word you said about that
story i'm like that yes
it's like it's obviously like why
wouldn't you do that right but sometimes
the most obvious things that
are the hardest to process the hardest
to to to achieve
and with my books and and my tours
you know i don't get people coming off
my tours going and
you know i've tapped into this part of
my brain now thank you for this it's
like
they come off my tools i'll read my
books and go it was always in there
yes you just gave me this kick yourself
moment where i'm just like
how did i not see that how did i not you
put it in such layman terms because i'm
i'm a simple man
i mean i'm not i'm not an intellect i'm
not a bookworm i'm i'm
i'm i'm a simpleton i'm a simple man i
keep things the way that i get to my
answers
is good bad right wrong positive
negative
yes no i mean i keep it and it's
listening but it's listening to who i am
and it's it's the most simplest way of
of
of getting to where you need to be
but we let the constraints
and the [ __ ] and the complications
of society and what other people
think cloud all of that
i almost see it like two dials right one
of them is this voice inside which
everyone has in them they say go and
dance in the hills of costa rica
and then there's this other really loud
dial right the sound dial
and it's society and your mom and your
whatever and that one's saying go be a
[ __ ] lawyer and shut up right
and in all of our lives i think one dial
is a little bit higher than the other
and the the the challenging thing but
the most important thing you can do if
you want to reach your potential be
happy avoid mental health issues avoid
midlife crises
is to like turn up the internal dial and
just try and get that that other dial
which is society's voice
right down to to [ __ ] zero
right and i and i just do you know i
just feel if everyone could just do that
in their own lives which is not easy to
do
because listening to this internal voice
is going to come with real resistance
people are going to cancel you they're
going to my mum's going to not speak to
me for years
right but that's the short time cost for
a long term gain and
as is the way with comfort i see like
comfort and like
avoiding with that resistance is a it
looks like a friend it's a short-term
friend but a long-term enemy
and if you you know if you had if you in
the moments where you've said you've
been like
cancelled quote-unquote um had you caved
short-term friend probably would still
have a show or two yeah of course
long-term belongs and i say to people
what you've got to realize is that you
are with yourself
24 hours a day for the rest of your life
no one else can even come close to that
no one else will will even come close to
that so you are with yourself
your whole life people they come and go
situations they come and go so
ultimately you've got to live with
yourself first
before you try and live with anyone else
before you try and live with any
situation before you try and
put yourself into any environment that's
what i say to people when they go well
i'm like you're with yourself 24 hours a
day to the day you die
nothing comes close to that no one comes
close to being anywhere near that
that's the person you've got on that's
who you are yeah so that's the person
who you've got to honor that's the
person that you've got to make
make happy boss that's the boss right
that's the person it's impossible to
please
that voice and that voice right so like
but please yourself and
and ultimately you know what comes out
it will
you know should should be war should be
authentic should be true
so and then you'll find your belonging
you'll find your circle you'll find
you're like-minded people you'll find
your
your your yeah you'll find your
belonging it's like
you know you must know
as you get more successful as you you
know you start thinking you start
changing start evolving your mindset
more and more and more and more
your circle gets smaller and smaller and
smaller and smaller i'm happy with that
you know i'm i'm happy with that because
not that i'm above anyone or below
anyone you know
we're just on different ends of the
spectrum okay because
guess what i'm going to keep evolving my
mindset's going to keep changing
i'm going to keep getting wise i'm going
to keep getting more knowledgeable i'm
going to keep being honest with myself
and for me that's my purpose in life
nothing out there you know it's nice to
have the nice cars and nice houses
don't get me wrong it's nice to have
money i've had no money and now i've got
money i know which side i'd rather be on
okay that's all but that's all that
comes
part and parcel with being true to who
you are um
and my purpose in life
which is i will never achieve but which
is
i find fascinating is
trying to get the best possible version
of ant middleton
trying to get to that okay but knowing
that i never get to that answer because
i'll be on this
constant progression of becoming a
better version of who i am
but i never become the best version of
who i am because
that's when you're perfect that's when
you're 100 you and that's
not real it doesn't exist but the
purpose of
getting closer and closer and closer and
closer to that answer
is such a fascinating journey for me
that there's nothing that comes close to
it
there's nothing that comes close to it
and whether i have the the counselling
or the shows that keep coming or the tv
production companies that call me now
and the channels that go whether i have
failures or whatever it may be all of
these everything
that bounces in towards me is a is
something to learn from
and it's a lesson and it's gonna i'm
gonna learn from it
and i'm gonna grow from it and i'm gonna
get closer and closer
to the answer closer and closer to
to my objective closer and closer to my
purpose and that is
to try and get as close as i can to
being the best version of myself
and i'm fascinated with it i'm addicted
by it i'm i'm addicted to it i'm i'm
obsessed with it
um so like i said when i get that thanos
moment
i'm like bring all this negativity at me
bring it because i'm just churning away
it
doesn't mean i'm always happy you know
i'm not always happy you know
you know i don't go around sprinkling
positive fairy dust i'm not that type of
preacher right
but i preach you know working on your
mind
to make it positive you know you know
challenging negative situation thinking
negative situation i've got a tackle
with a positive mindset make a
conservative effort to train your
mindset
to think positively to flip the script
from this default mindset where everyone
you know thinks
thinks negatively um and i love working
at that i love working out so all of
this stuff that you give me it does
once i got because i go quiet like this
last week has been a media storm
and i'll go quiet and i'll be with with
my family i'll be with my management
they're like aren't you quiet i'm quiet
because i'm churning
away at negativity i'm not unhappy don't
get me wrong listen
but i need to be left alone for two
three days maybe a week
because there's so much negativity
coming in and i'm chipping away trying
to find the light no nothing there
and i find the light trying to find boom
bang
and then i bank this positivity
and then the next week i'll be boom
back to ant do i mean back to this
positive naturally positive person
because i've trained my mind to think
like that i'm always in a positive head
space
um but sometimes i'll go quiet doesn't
mean i'm always happy so don't get don't
get positivity mixed up with happiness
yeah yeah because they're two completely
different things and happiness comes
from yeah
in knowing who you are you know it comes
from from being true to you are knowing
who you are and
you could be the poorest man in the
world and you could be there you know
you could have no one or nothing but you
could still be happy you know you could
be the richest man in the world and you
know you know you know the script
um one of them's like a general sense of
optimism
that i'm positive about the future the
other one's just like internal
contentment
and and um but our moods change yeah of
course you know we have
[ __ ] days bad days whatever but we're
optimistic and tight right yeah one of
the questions i really wanted to
ask you because of what's going on in
the world with this whole pandemic in
covid
is i was thinking as i was like brushing
my teeth or whatever this morning i was
thinking
there's a ton if my audience could ask
you one thing probably would be
around the fact that the world changed
this year a lot of people's lives
were uprooted they lost their businesses
their jobs whatever
and then i thought you know ants
probably well i for sure have been in
situations where you felt like
whether whether it's on the battlefield
or whatever that this was a fight that
you where the odds were against you yeah
and in those moments there's winners and
losers
and i you know you always talk about
mindset what is the mindset that people
need
in these moments where the odds don't
look like they're they're very much in
their favor
from that you've seen from the
battlefield where you've emerged
victorious
because you know you didn't you didn't
indulge in victimhood or whatever
and you and you yeah does that make
sense yeah it 100 makes sense
um for me it hasn't
it's about embracing change you know
majority of people they live their life
on autopilot or they
they live in the void i call it um
where everything around them is changing
you know the world is
constantly changing everything around us
is constantly changing whether it's
you know climate control whether it's
you know
in the way that we think the way that
we're evolving the way that the world is
going the way that
animals are evolving the way that the
sea is
is is encroaching or you know decreasing
whatever it may be
everything is changing around us and we
are designed
to change with it so what we're actually
doing is we're actually going against
the grain
when we become complacent when we get
comfortable
when we get into one sort of situation
and we stay in that situation it's going
we go we're working in the opposite way
that the world should be evolving
we should be constantly changing we
should be constantly evolving we should
be constantly moving forward
you know look at my career i've gone
from the army to the marines to the
special forces to the media
to to books to authors to literacy to
business it's like
i'm cons i love love change i love
being put in a situation where i'm
literally chucked in the deep end with
dive boots on and i have to tread water
i love that because it's so challenging
and it's so
so stimulating that you're forced to
change
you're forced to think of something
different you're forced to to to do
something differently you're forced to
change the way that you
you approach something because you've
been put in a situation where
it's been forced upon you but when it's
not forced upon you
when it's not forced upon you um which
the world does it forces it upon us but
when it's not forced upon you when you
when you get comfortable then
you get you fall into this voyage you
fall into this complacency you fall into
to not moving along with the world
but is that those your demons again
because i'm thinking
the reason why aunt loves to be chucked
into the water with his dive boots on
is because you relish challenge and this
is comes
maybe links to the victimhood point and
a general problem in culture and society
where
people like comfort cotton wool yeah a
lot of people are being
brought up now with cottonwood not
designed we're not designed to be
comfortable
we're not designed to have cotton walls
wrapped around us it's society it's the
restraints and the shackles of society
that is forcing us to be like this
it's not who we are look how far we've
come
you know look out look at look at just
through history
how far we've come and i feel like that
we're actually devolving now
i actually feel that we've got to a
point where we're going backwards
where you know you used to be survivor
of the fitness yes
you could push a rock in front of your
cave you know i mean to survive you know
used to be at the you know the top of
the food chain
um you know it's we're not designed
to be comfortable we're not designed to
be wrapped up in cotton wool we're not
designed to be shackled down and that's
why there's so many problems
in the world right now is because of
these shackles
is because of these chains it's because
of the restraints that society is
putting on us
it's forcing us into into mental illness
it's forcing us to to act in ways that
we're not designed to act in
is forcing us to to switch off to the
most powerful tool
that the universe that's in the universe
your minds
we're forced to just put it on [ __ ]
dormant you know that be a
it's it's we're going against the grain
of what we're supposed to do
of who we're supposed to be on how we're
supposed to act and how is
it um supposed to evolve so when when
you've got this going around like this
and then this stops is
it you you there's a synchronocity
that's not working in
in in partnership with each other you
know without us on this planet this
planet wouldn't be
as evolved as it was without the planet
then we wouldn't be evolved as it was
you know and what what's actually
happening is is you've got this
this this these two forces that
are grinding against each other rather
than working together
with each other in synchronocity i i i
was reading this crazy thing the other
day
and i think i've talked about this maybe
once before but it shows that um
the life expectancy in the uk and the us
fell for two years in a row
and everything was like last year the
year before whatever for the first time
ever and they look at the numbers
as to why the life expectancy has fallen
to the first time ever and it's because
of like the opioid crisis
people who are getting addicted to drugs
and then they say why are people getting
more and more addicted to drugs and they
say well because they're lacking meaning
in their life
and when people like meaning that the
science is showing whether you do it to
animals you take away their meaning
i i talked i think in the last podcast
and i i hate to repeat myself but i also
don't care
about these rats and i [ __ ] because
they're right about my bucket so
fascinated by it they put a rat in a
cage and take everything from it
and they give it the option of drinking
hair and water and normal water it
becomes a drug addict
they then introduce a partner some
stimulation some
running wheels some other things and
they give it hair and water or normal
water and it doesn't choose the heroin
water it doesn't become a drug addict
just by inserting meaning into its life
it avoids the heroin and then you think
okay so
what's going on in the society you say
well people are lacking
challenge and meaning because we're
trying to create a culture maybe where
challenge and meaning are a bad thing
and and that's actually having an
adverse effect because as you say
very eloquently like that's not who we
are you know i love how you just put
that steve because you've just
put my thoughts into a scientific sort
of
into scientific form because again i'm
not an intellect i'm not a bookworm you
know it's it's like i have
psychiatrists come up to me and go where
did you just study and well but not
honestly what brexit
and i'm like no no this is all every
single little ounce of me is through
life experience
i come from the university of life you
know what i've just said there's it's
strange that
and that's why i love talking to people
like yourself because
i've put that as in how i'm thinking i
haven't read anything from
and you've just put it into a whole sort
of scientific and it's like
that's exactly that it's exactly what
i've just said and you've just put it
into
into something that's been proven and
that's that's the way that i think
that's the way that i
that's the way that i perceive life and
it's funny because as you say you're not
you didn't see it i'm not an
intellectual but i've sat here with
intellectuals and they've said the exact
same thing like johanna hari
he wrote a book on this nine reasons why
people are getting depressed and anxious
best-selling book he sat here and he
said the exact same thing so when i hear
it twice or three times and then i read
it another
i think these are just fundamental
truths and when i get to that point
where you've been you've walked a
different walk of life to that that
intellect who's wrote a book on it but
you've both arrived at the same place
that's going in my [ __ ] like in my
diary forever you know
that's that's super interesting as well
it's like you know you you
but you can't take away that you know
you can't
you can't unwrite that because it's
written within evolution
it's written within the way the world it
has evolved it's written in the way that
we think
it's written in in the organs the
muscles and
the body that we have it's all here it's
all [ __ ] present right now
yeah it's not in a book that we're going
to read it it's [ __ ] happening right
now it's here it's real
this energy source that you are your
[ __ ] energy source where energy
sources
is synchronized with the planet which is
one big energy source it's one big ball
and i'd have had a moment of clarity on
on when i was filming
i've always felt connection with the
earth you know i talk about
you know we can climb to the highest
peak of
the apex of the world mount everest we
can climb to that because people said
yeah but we've had to do this
this and this in order to get there you
know working against the mountain i'm
not know
the way that that mountain is formed is
that's a foothold for you
that's a that's an arm reach for you
that's you know it's that
it's designed to work with you so don't
look at a mountain and go off can i go
get up there it's working against me no
no it's
that little stone there that you put
your foot that's helping you up
to to to stand on on its apex it's
helping you up to stand on its summit
and um i've always felt a connection
with
the earth always always always you know
when i put my feet in it when i put my
hands in it
you know i belong here you know and i
have this sort of
i have this theory that people think
that you know
that if you put the planet as a as a as
a tree where they think we're just birds
that come and sit on the tree and i
think we're just visitors and then and
then we go we're not
we're we're the leaves yeah we're the
leaves of the tree
i mean and then you know we grow in that
we're part of
you know we're part of this evolution
it's spiritual but yeah yeah
i'm not a spiritual person but maybe you
are but maybe your definition's wrong
because i posted on my instagram last
week yeah i did so
we've just had it's funny my instagram
post literally says i've never thought
of myself as a spiritual person because
i don't resonate with like the hippie
stigma
yeah yeah like i'm not that guy however
the end it's one story
right the end of it was like i if you
define
as feeling somewhat connected to the
world which i now do
then i now consider myself to be
spiritual this was just one story and
this was like three days ago
because a lot of people do ask if i'm
spiritual and i i always say no
but yeah maybe i am but it's that's that
theory of
of being there's a con you know
connection there's one currently from
the other and when when that when you
know we're the leaves yeah we're gonna
fall off and there's gonna be new leaves
you know
but everything recycles back into itself
do you know when we don't just
all of a sudden go up into you know
everything goes back into the earth
everything really generally spiritual
because i i went and googled it
definition of spirituality
and the definition i read was like the
feeling or belief that we are
interconnected with the world
the stigma is the issue that's what
alienates both of us from saying i'm a
spiritual
because we're not like hippies we're not
like you know but we are we like i love
that you know what i mean so
and i go about going back to this moment
where i've where it just resonates you
know
and the reason why i do all these things
is i just want to reconfirm that my way
of thinking
is is true is true to me is is why i do
this you know
and that's why i put myself in these
awkward situations because it just
it gives a light bulb moment where i go
do you know what bloody hell you know
i'm i'm on the right path i'm getting
this right
and um as i wait i was away filming
and i felt this you know i was out in
the mountains in um
in chile in the andes and i could just
feel a real connection you know
like a like a real presence
you know and it's it's just a lovely
lovely feeling and i can just remember
just a an energy connection it was
really strange that it happened
an energy connection and i was walking
by i was walking a lot alongside of this
mountain and i was walking
alongside i heard a big massive bang and
i turned towards
the mountain and i'm not joking it was
probably about 300 meters away
so it's like you know and this bit of
rock went
it must have passed no no word of a lie
within two meters of me
you know and a big one because the
mountains
it's an energy source they're [ __ ]
bursting they're literally like that
and the mountain every now and then and
it's the first time i experienced it i
heard about it but i've never
experienced it and i went bang
and it nearly took my head off to the
point where i was like
[ __ ] health was incoming you know i
was like
and then i realized i was like well just
and you see a little bit of
mount mountain fall off by one bomb and
it's where the energy
the energy of that mountain and you know
unless you get out and about you see
it's like
and i thought to myself wow i remember
stopping and thinking
i felt that before that even not that
specific
moment but i felt the energy so i felt
the connection there
and then that was it's almost as if the
mountain was talking to me going
what you feeling is right listen we are
listen
we are powerful we have a connection
without you there wouldn't be me without
me that wouldn't be you
and just that confirmation just makes me
realize
wow you know this is this is this is
powerful stuff this is you know
this is how you should be feeling once
you're in tune with yourself
and then and and and connected to the to
this planet
then there's there's there's not much
that you feel that you can't do there's
not much that phases you in life there's
not much that you won't try and achieve
there's no
there's not much that you won't achieve
and i feel
i feel sorry or because you can i can
talk about being in tune
with with the planet and being you know
being connected to
to mother earth but unless you
are in tune with that then you just
think i'm talking bollocks you just
think
what the hell is he on about he's some
spiritual idiot blah blah blah blah blah
so
you know this is the personal life that
i really keep to myself you know i've
spoken a lot about it today which i've
never spoken about before
but this is this is who i am i mean so
there's there's so much more behind
what the media put out and what the what
the papers put out and what the
you know the media agenda is on what
they want you to be seen as
and there's this whole life behind me
that is
that i just that's the real me that's
who i
am so when any of this other stuff
that's made up by other people that
comes in from
from not within it is so easy for me
just to battle
so easy for me just go bang bang bang
but don't get me wrong sometimes i work
harder at it to batter off
sometimes it does stick and you have to
go all right
but it's such a liberating feeling and
i'll always say to people and this is
this this is my you know find out who
you are
go on that journey not self-discovery
because that sounds spiritual right go
on that journey of of
finding your purpose of fun of becoming
the best version of who you are because
once you start that journey
you will get addicted to it it is
fascinating and it will
it will only serve you well he will only
serve you well because it's a life
i want i want to live till i'm 150
because you say i live to
until i'm 50 a hundred 100 years isn't
long enough i still want more i want to
know more i want to i want to be on this
journey for them
for as long as i can be on this journey
this is what gives me longevity this is
what gives me purpose
i want to be on this journey for as long
as i can be and when i think
the only setback is when i think you
know i've got another
you know 50 60 years of it it sort of
saddens me so uh
i'm hoping that by that stage we can we
can live to be
a bit bit more immortal a bit more a bit
more immortal
oh yeah well listen um i think that's a
really powerful place to end
and i think that's um that's something
that i'll continue to point out i wanted
to say thank you though because there
are a few people that are
have the courage in this day and age to
be themselves and to speak their mind
and that
and unfortunately it feels like a bit of
a dying breed but you're one of those
people and
having spent time with you before we
started filming and during this
conversation i got to know
i had the privilege of getting to know
who you are a little bit as you say and
um
that's a person that i do respect one
that inspires me and reminds me of the
importance of following my
my truer self so i just wanted to say
thank you thank you for having this
conversation today and thank you for
being yourself
save your gentleman thank you thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign